digital marketing is the lifeblade of
modern business strategies with billions
invested in digital advertising each
year the integration of digital
Technologies has transformed consumer
brand interactions and purchasing
decisions establishing a strong digital
marketing presence is essential for
businesses to expand their customer base
Drive sales and establish an online
brand presence noteworthy strategies
include social media campaigns search
engine optimization email marketing
influencer marketing content marketing
and PPC advertising the field of digital
marketing is witnessing rapid expansion
opening up numerous career prospects for
individuals with relevant skills these
are various roles available in this
domain such as digital marketing manager
social media manager SEO specialist
content marketing manager and email
marketing specialist those passionate
about leveraging digital channels to
drive business business growth can
anticipate exciting opportunities in
this Dynamic industry according to Glass
2 Data the average annual salary for
digital marketing Professionals in the
United States is approximately 130 000
in India the average annual salary is 10
lakh leading companies in the digital
marketing field include VMware Infosys
Accenture ey Amazon Oracle Dell and
Linkedin this industry Giants offer
exciting prospects for professionals
equipped with digital marketing
expertise hi everyone welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel this digital
marketing skills will guide you in
navigating the path towards building a
successful career in this Dynamic field
of digital marketing on that note if you
are passionate about digital marketing
and have aspiration to advance your
career in this field then seize the
opportunity to enroll in the highly
acclaimed postgraduate program in
digital marketing this program offered
by marketing land and search engine
Journal is recognized worldwide and
allows you to earn a prestigious digital
marketer certification from Purdue
University you will develop website
creation and promotion expertise through
a series of live Interactive Learning
sessions the program offers a
comprehensive curriculum that covers
both fundamental and advanced digital
marketing skills Harvard Business
publishing cases and 20 plus projects
chat GPT AI tools real life cases and
exposure to 35 Plus digital marketing
tools are encrypted to provide a
holistic learning experience this course
is designed to equip you with the
knowledge and skills needed to excel in
your digital marketing career as an
added benefit you will receive a
meta-certified digital marketing
associate exam boarder with USD 99
enabling you to demonstrate your
acquired expertise broadly throughout
the program you will follow a structured
learning path that encompasses essential
areas such as website creation
exploration of the digital marketing
landscape Behavior marketing search
engine optimization search in engine
marketing social media marketing
strategies and the potential of email
marketing furthermore the program offers
elective options including blogging
affiliate marketing B2B marketing and
other exciting Avenues to delve into
allowing you to customize your learning
experience according to your interest
and career goals if you want to know
more about this intensive course do
check out the link in the description
box digital marketing skills are
essential for Effective online marketing
and promotion some key skills include
search engine optimization understanding
SEO principles and techniques to
optimize website content and keywords
for higher search engine rankings and
visibility next pay per click
advertising Proficiency in managing and
optimizing PPC campaigns on platforms
like Google ads Bing ads and social
media advertising platforms to drive
targeted traffic and conversions next we
have social media marketing knowledge of
various social media platforms such as
Facebook book Twitter Instagram and
Linkedin and the ability to create
engaging content run effective campaigns
and analyze performance metrics next
content marketing creating and
distributing valuable and relevant
content to attack and engage target
audience including blog posts videos
infographics and ebooks and then we have
email marketing developing email
marketing strategies creating compelling
email campaigns managing subscriber list
and analyzing email campaigns Matrix for
improve engagement and conversions then
conversion rate optimization
understanding user experience design
principles conducting a b testing and
implementing strategies to optimize
website and leading page elements for
higher conversion rates mobile marketing
knowledge of mobile marketing strategies
including mobile app marketing mobile
advertising and responsive design to
reach and engage mobile user effectively
next digital advertising and remarketing
experience in running display ads
retargeting campaigns and leveraging AD
networks such as Google Display Network
to reach potential customers across
various websites and platforms and at
last influencer marketing understanding
how to identify and collaborate with
influences to promote products or
services and increase brand awareness
and credibility these are just a few of
the essential digital marketing skills
as the digital landscape evolves it's
important for digital marketers to
continuously update their skills and
stay updated about emerging Trends and
Technologies now that you are aware of
digital marketing skills the simply
learns postgraduate program will equip
you with all the necessary skills
including website creation Behavior
marketing keyword research search engine
optimization search engine marketing
campaign management social media
marketing mobile marketing content
marketing and content strategy not only
the skills but it also covers tools and
Technology to such as SC ranking chat
GPT Facebook LinkedIn YouTube Google ads
Google Keyword Planner YouTube analytics
Google Trends and many more also embark
on exciting industry projects that
provide hands-on experience and
practical insights so hurry up find the
course Link in the description box for
more details our Learners have
experienced huge success in their career
listen to their experience find this
influence Course Review Link in the
description box with this we have come
to the end of this digital marketing
skills if you like this video subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn if you need any help opting
for this course please let us know in
the comment section below we will get
back to you as soon as possible until
next time thank you and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign